alors si vous me demandez laquelle est
la meilleure honnêtement je crois que je
pourrais pas vous répondre déjà parce
que je tourne à 9h du matin aujourd'hui
donc c'est pas vraiment le meilleur
moment pour prendre un soda et puis plus
généralement je suis pas vraiment fan ni
de l'un ni l'autre par contre je peux
vous raconter l'histoire de cette guerre
la guerre entre les deux géants du soda
j'ai nommé donc d'un côté Pepsi et de
l'autre Coca-Cola mais juste avant de
s'attaquer à ces deux mastodontes du
marché changement de vêtements
changements capillaire aussi depuis le
temps si vous n'êtes pas le patron de
coca de Pepsi ou autre mais que vous
voulez lancer votre propre entreprise ou
alors plus généralement quelconque
projet et bien audou qui est partenaire
de cette vidéo va très certainement
pouvoir vous aider en fait c'est un
logiciel qui s'adresse aux entrepreneurs
et aux PME pour leur permettre de mieux
gérer leur entreprise vous avez
plusieurs applications qui répondent à
des besoins différents comme entre
autres la facturation les ventes les
événements la gestion des inventaires et
également un éditeur de site internet la
plateforme est très simple d'utilisation
est très intuitive en fait vous n'avez
pas besoin d'avoir des compétences en
informatique il suffit juste de déplacer
des blocs pour créer les pages de votre
site forcément c'est idéal parce que
même si vous n'y connaissez pas grand
chose en informatique comme moi et bien
vous pouvez tout de même lancer un site
internet ou alors un e-commerce en
quelques clics sans avoir besoin de
coder en plus de ça c'est avantageux
puisque la première application utilisée
est gratuite à vie donc vous pouvez
créer votre site web ou votre site
e-commerce sans avoir à payer quoi que
ce soit l'hébergement et le support sont
inclus en illimité il y a un nom de
domaine personnalisé est offert pendant
un an donc si vous avez besoin de créer
un site internet n'hésitez pas à cliquer
sur le lien qui est directement en
description je vous laisse tout de suite
avec la suite de la vidéo alors
aujourd'hui on a tendance à dire que
Coca-Cola domine le marché et c'est vrai
qu'au début il était clairement favori
mais c'était sans compter sur les
efforts de Pepsi pour le détrôner et
même d'ailleurs lui faire frôler sa
chute alors comme tous les duels il ne
peut y avoir qu'un vainqueur aujourd'hui
qui remporte la bataille du soda après
avoir fait plusieurs vidéos sur des
conflits mondiaux aujourd'hui on se
plonge dans un conflit un peu plus léger
certes mais controversé et passionnant
vous allez le voir il y a pas mal de
rebondissements et il y a même Michael
Jackson qui a participé alors
installez-vous prenez quelque chose à
boire pas forcément un soda d'ailleurs
ce que vous voulez et on est donc parti
alors commençons par le commencement
petit retour en arrière puisque c'est
dans les années 1800 que Pepsi et
Coca-Cola ont été tous les deux inventés
et des marrons sans plus tarder avec
coca alors on est en 1886 lorsque un
pharmacien américain du nom de John
Everton cherche à développer une boisson
qui lui permettrait de mettre fin à sa
propre addiction à la morphine en effet
John Pemberton c'est aussi un ancien
soldat il est devenu complètement accro
à la morphine pour soulager ses
blessures du coup afin de se
désintoxiquer de la morphine il invente
une boisson une boisson composée
attention de 20 français d'un fruit sec
appelé noix de cola et d'une plante
d'Amérique du Sud connue pour ses vertus
médicinales j'ai nommé le coca péruvien
et c'est ainsi donc que naît à l'époque
le french wine coca mais le bonheur et
le soulagement va être de très courte
durée pour John Pemberton en effet cette
même année la ville d'Atlanta aux
États-Unis impose la prohibition qui
interdit donc la production
l'importation et la vente de boissons
alcoolisées comme par exemple donc le
vin français Pemberton va alors chercher
à remplacer le vin de son mélange il
invente donc une boisson non alcoolisée
cette fois-ci vous me voyez venir c'est
la naissance de Coca-Cola alors au
passage pour la petite histoire et vous
commencez peut-être à le comprendre
beaucoup de sodas ont été inventés par
des pharmaciens comme ici donc avec
Pemberton pour le coca pour la simple et
bonne raison que ces sodas étaient à
l'origine destiné à soulager des
problèmes de santé c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que le docteur Pepper s'appelle comme
ça lui aussi a été inventé par
pharmacien au Texas c'est donc comme ça
qui est né le Coca-Cola la fameuse
boisson dont la recette serait aussi
secrète que les codes de l'arme
nucléaire même si bon en réalité c'est
un peu un mythe on connaît aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de sa recette du coup on
arrive sept ans plus tard quand un autre
pharmacien américain du nom de Calais
bradham développe lui aussi une nouvelle
boisson une boisson qui combine
notamment de l'eau gazeuse de la noix de
cola du caramel et du sucre il a donc
vous me voyez venir c'est un cycle Pepsi
est né enfin presque d'ailleurs puisque
Caleb bradam décide d'appeler sa boisson
la boisson de Brad poisson de Brad c'est
pas ouf c'est pour ça qu'il le renomme
trois ans plus tard Pepsi Cola et
d'ailleurs petite anecdote en fait en
grec Pepsi ça veut dire digestion on
voit là donc la vertu médicale pour
apaiser certaines douleurs alors après
évidemment et c'est le cas aussi pour
Coca-Cola les clients des pharmacies ont
commencé à acheter des sodas tout
simplement parce que ils trouvaient ça
bon et rafraîchissant pas forcément pour
apaiser des douleurs en tout cas les
boissons prennent de l'ampleur on va
avancer de quelques années entre temps
chaque pharmacien dépose le nom de sa
marque et les deux entreprises sont donc
opérationnelles ça fonctionne plutôt
bien très Coca-Cola va devenir leader et
va dominer très clairement le marché et
ça d'ailleurs sur toute la première
moitié du 20e siècle de son côté Pepsi
Cola rame rame beaucoup en fait et fait
même faillite en 1923 en fait
l'entreprise n'est plus capable de payer
le sucre pour fabriquer son soda elle
est donc mise à l'arrêt jusqu'à nouvel
ordre du coup pendant ce temps là et
bien tout va bien du côté de coca la vie
est belle la marque est installée
partout aux États-Unis mais ça ne lui
suffit pas Coca-Cola veut plus que ça
Coca-Cola veut plus que les États-Unis
elle veut s'exporter dans le monde
entier et c'est à ce moment-là donc que
Coca décide de tenter un coup de poker
avec une campagne de publicité
internationale et cette mascotte vous le
voyez ce n'est pas n'importe qui
alors il faut savoir que Coca-Cola a
clairement contribué à fixer l'image du
père Noël dans les esprits du monde
entier grâce à cette publicité et si
aujourd'hui on représente le Père Noël
avec sa tenue rouge la fourrure blanche
au manche ou encore son ventre rond et
sa barbe et bien c'est en grande partie
suite à Coca-Cola Coca-Cola rapproche
les gens Coca-Cola réunit les familles
bref c'est des éléments de langage qui
sont martelés à travers cette campagne
publicitaire et c'est tout simplement un
énorme succès à la veille de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la marque est donc
présente dans 44 pays alors comment
est-ce que Pepsi peut essayer de
rattraper son retard après tout ça et
bien après sa faillite l'entreprise est
rachetée par un certain Charles goutte
ou Charles Guth je sais jamais comment
prononcer son nom c'est le président de
loft une grosse entreprise qui fabrique
et vend des bonbons dans les années 20
on arrive donc dans dans les années 30 à
ce moment là et le monde traverse une
grave crise économique après le krach
boursier américain de 1929 du coup dans
cette période de grande crise Pepsi se
dit qu'il faut absolument baisser les
prix pour que les gens continuent
d'acheter du soda malgré tout cent ans
que Coca-Cola s'apprête à prendre son
envol Pepsi décide de lancer sa toute
première campagne de publicité à la
radio
[Musique]
alors évidemment sauf si vous êtes
américain et que vous avez peut-être
trois fois mon âge ce slogan twice
asmatch pour une école donc deux fois
plus pour nickel donc une pièce de 5
centimes aux États-Unis et bien c'est un
slogan qui est inconnu pour nous mais
qui est resté très longtemps dans la
tête des générations qui ont suivis aux
États-Unis et d'ailleurs pour
information encore aujourd'hui pour la
plupart des pays du monde un litre de PE
et moins cher qu'un litre de coca ok
donc Pepsi vient de marquer un point ces
ventes sont en hausse ça va plutôt pas
mal finalement pour Pepsi et vous vous
en doutez coca n'a pas prévu de se
laisser abattre par une campagne de
publicité à la radio bien au contraire
là ils peuvent être efforts et elle va
même devenir l'un des plus gros
partenariats de tous les temps et oui
c'est de cette époque que vient ce
partenariat et donc cette fameuse
question frite coca depuis 1955 donc
McDonald's et Coca-Cola sont liés par un
partenariat très fort et c'est
d'ailleurs cette année là que le tout
premier restaurant McDonald's ouvre près
de Chicago aux États-Unis et propose
alors ses premiers menus avec McDonald's
Coca-Cola va même lancer un produit
dérié que vous avez tous déjà vu passer
voir que vous avez peut-être chez vous
ou chez vos parents c'est les fameux
verres coca du McDo alors Pepsi décide
de s'inspirer de coca dans cette idée de
partenariat ils comprennent bien que
l'idée d'associer la boisson à d'autres
aliments et tout simplement un repas et
quelque chose qui peut pas mal
fonctionner nous sommes donc en 1965
près de 10 ans plus tard lorsque la
marque Pepsi décide de fusionner avec
Free toilettes alors fritole je suis
d'accord quand on en parle comme ça
c'est pareil très mystérieux mais en
fait c'est un immense groupe alimentaire
qui possède notamment les chips lays
Cheetos ou encore Doritos avec cette
alliance entre la boisson et ses
aliments le groupe PepsiCo comme il
s'appelle maintenant arrive donc à s'en
créer lui aussi dans les restaurants et
surtout dans les supermarchés pour
tenter là aussi de concurrencer un petit
peu coca mais si on avance un peu c'est
véritablement avec le Pepsi challenge
lancé en 1975 que la marque va propulser
ses ventes
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est bien en fait c'est
une grande campagne de publicité qui a
été annoncée par un petit génie chez
Pepsi l'idée de ce Pepsi challenge est
très très simple organiser des tests
géants auprès du grand public en leur
proposant de choisir à l'aveugle quel
soda donc est le meilleur entre Pepsi et
coca
joyeux
comment Pepsi pouvait être aussi certain
de gagner ce duel et la réponse elle
tient en un mot le sucre Pepsi a en
effet une concentration supérieure en
sucre par rapport à coca et donc le
palais est attiré par ça chez pas mal de
personnes et d'ailleurs on peut noter
qu'avec ce Pepsi challenge il y a eu une
nouvelle manière de communiquer sur une
marque on est ici sur une stratégie de
communication agressive basée donc sur
la comparaison directe avec un produit
concurrent ici donc entre deux boissons
et récemment vous l'avez peut-être vu
encore il y a quelques jours c'est
Burger King qui fait énormément ça pour
essayer de se
[Musique]
comme on l'appelle en France un
Coca-Cola donc avec moins de sucre on
est alors en 1982 et c'est le début d'un
énorme succès un succès partout dans le
monde et pourtant ce qui est étonnant
c'est que ce n'est pas Coca-Cola qui
avait inventé le soda avec moins de
sucre Pepsi avait déjà lancé son diet
Pepsi en 1964 donc quasiment 20 ans
avant coca mais à l'époque le Pepsi
light ne fonctionnait pas et donc 20 ans
après Coca-Cola largement dépassé bref
toujours dans cette volonté de devenir
le numéro 1 du marché Pepsi et décide
alors d'utiliser les mêmes armes que son
adversaire a priori vous vous souvenez
du Père Noël de Coca-Cola à l'instant et
bien difficile de faire mieux à moins
que
tu as choisi
[Musique]
Michael Jackson le roi de la pop la plus
grande star du moment entre dans la
guerre des sodas nous sommes alors en
1983 après l'énorme succès de Thriller
Michael Jackson signe en effet un
contrat historique avec PepsiCo pour ça
il reçoit un chèque de 5 millions de
dollars un montant record pour l'époque
et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs si on prend en
compte l'inflation etc ce serait
l'équivalent de 15 millions de dollars
et si aujourd'hui et bien ça n'a rien
d'incroyable de faire appel à une
célébrité pour faire la promotion de son
entreprise à l'époque ce n'est pas
nouveau mais faire appel qui aime à une
telle célébrité que Michael Jackson
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
inédit finalement là où Coca-Cola a pris
l'incarnation d'un personnage qui a la
base n'existait pas ouh là montrez pas
du coup cette vidéo à des enfants et
bien Pepsi mais la main sur une égérie
qui plait à toutes les générations
Michael Jackson a même quasiment un rôle
de directeur artistique dans ce
partenariat il reprend lui-même sa
célèbre chanson Billie Jean mais à la
sauce Pepsi avec une phrase d'ailleurs
qui va marquer les esprits Yorub Pepsi
generation petite anecdote d'ailleurs où
il y a beaucoup d'anecdotes vous l'aurez
compris dans cette vidéo Michael Jackson
a bien failli mourir lors d'un tournage
du Pepsi Oui-Oui c'était en 1984 un an
après le début de leur collaboration un
fumigène installé pour le tournage c'est
déclencher trop tôt il y a mis le feu à
ses cheveux alors Michael Jackson ne
sont pas aperçu tout de suite il a
continué à danser quelques secondes
avant de s'effondrer le chanteur est
alors brûlé au visage et aux cheveux
mais finalement heureusement plus de
peur que de mal et ça n'aura pas de
conséquences sur la collaboration entre
le roi de la pop et Pepsi qui continue
d'ailleurs d'utiliser l'image du
chanteur même après sa mort
de mettre une raclée à son concurrent
historique Coca-Cola perd du terrain et
aujourd'hui avec leur cul et bien on
peut le dire Pepsi a bien failli couler
Coca-Cola avec Michael Jackson là où la
marque possédait 60% des parts de marché
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale elle
retombe à 20% au milieu des années 80
bref pour Coca-Cola l'heure est grave il
est plus que temps de riposter alors en
1985 Coca-Cola a une idée
révolutionnaire changer sa recette
historique pour marquer un grand coup
mais ça va devenir tout simplement la
pire erreur de son histoire
adieu le Coca-Cola bonjour donc le New
Cook nouveau nom nouvelle recette mais
surtout nouveau fiasco pour dire les
choses simplement ça provoque en fait
une colère importante des Américains en
gros comment ont-ils osé toucher à cette
recette sacrée
il faut bien comprendre à ce moment-là
le symbole que représente Coca-Cola pour
beaucoup d'Américains c'est pas juste
une boisson mais c'est l'un des emblèmes
de l'Amérique l'une des boissons qui
s'étend partout dans le monde et on ne
touche pas aux emblèmes de l'Amérique
[Musique]
à l'époque cette histoire est vraiment
énorme les gens appellent au boycott
même de la marque les ventes donc chutes
évidemment donc coca a fini par revenir
en arrière et 77 jours après son retrait
la formule originale de Coca-Cola
revient dans les rayons et le mal est
fait l'impact sur les ventes est
tellement gros que suite à ce retour en
arrière et pour bien faire comprendre
que maintenant c'était le retour de la
boisson originale et pas du nouveau coca
bien Coca-Cola pendant près de 20 ans a
dû écrire classique sur toutes ces
boissons de coca bref ça reste à ce jour
l'échec le plus humiliant pour la marque
et Pepsi va même utiliser les malheurs
de coca pour illustrer ses propres
publicités
[Musique]
et comme Coca-Cola a su réagir et
rebondir à temps la marque s'en sort
finalement plutôt bien les ventes
finissent par revenir finalement en
créant un effet de nouveauté sur quelque
chose qui n'était pas nouveau à savoir
le Coca-Cola classique des millions de
personnes donc se ruent sur le retour du
Coca-Cola classique stage demandé
finalement s'ils avaient pas fait exprès
au départ pour relancer cette boisson
originale on avance donc de quelques
années nous sommes désormais en 1991 et
ça y est l'effet retour du coca
classique commence à s'estomper la
marque décide alors de lancer une
nouvelle campagne de publicité le
problème c'est que avec Michael Jackson
et depuis quelques années Pepsi assure
pas mal quand même sur ce terrain là
jusqu'à ce que et bien un homme arrive
cet homme c'est Ken Stewart producteur
de cinéma qui a une idée de génie pour
Coca en fait Ken Stuart était chez lui
tranquillement il se demande ce qui va
bien pouvoir proposer comme public c'est
un Coca-Cola alors il commence à
s'imaginer au cinéma en train de boire
un coca et à côté de lui bien il y a son
petit chien un chien dont la tête
ressemble un petit peu à un ours polaire
selon lui et c'est comme ça que l'idée
d'une nouvelle publicité aînée emmenée
des ours polaires au cinéma et voilà
donc ce que ça a donné
[Musique]
et c'est donc un tout nouveau personnage
emblématique pour la marque par la suite
qui est créée
[Musique]
Coca-Cola donc a enfin trouvé une
manière de rivaliser avec les pubs de
Pepsi et leur célébrité mais à force
d'être concentré sur leur bataille qui
dure finalement depuis près d'un siècle
les deux concurrents finissent par
oublier de regarder les autres
adversaires potentiels dans les années
90 Coca-Cola a repris sa position de
leader et l'entreprise s'est développée
à tel point qu'elle passe des accords
avec des établissements scolaires oui
oui des établissements scolaires donc
des écoles aux États-Unis pour y
installer ceci des distributeurs de
sodas pour les collèges et les lycées
c'est un moyen de faire entrer un peu
d'argent et pour les distributeurs
forcément un moyen d'occuper un marché
super intéressant Pepsi va d'ailleurs
faire à la même chose le problème c'est
que si ça plaît aux ados ça plaît
beaucoup moins aux parents et aux
médecins qui voient des réels dangers
pour la santé des enfants au fil des
années plusieurs médias commencent à
relayer des enquêtes et des études qui
démontrent l'impact négatif des sodas
sur la santé des gens notamment
concernant l'augmentation de l'obésité
dans le monde l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé qualifie même d'épidémie
l'augmentation fulgurante du taux de
surpoids et d'obésité qui a lieu dans
les années 80 dans le monde et en
particulier d'ailleurs aux États-Unis en
fait aujourd'hui on sait que même une
seule canette de soda sucrée par jour et
bien c'est déjà trop et ça peut avoir
des conséquences graves sur notre santé
par exemple sur notre foi
il faudra quand même me surveiller ce
fourni les sodas aurait également
responsables de l'apparition du diabète
une maladie caractérisée par la présence
d'un excès de sucre dans le sang bref je
fais un mini saut dans le temps mais
forcément tout ça a fini par avoir un
impact visible sur les ventes des deux
géants du soda depuis la fin des années
90 en fait ça touche toutes les marques
de soda et tous les produits transformés
plus généralement il y a donc une chute
des ventes progressivement il faut
savoir que les marques à ce moment-là
elles ont conscience de ça et on se sent
c'est bien elle tente d'agir pour
limiter cet impact négatif et là je
parle de l'impact négatif sur les ventes
passent sur la santé Coca-Cola et Pepsi
ont déjà été accusés à de nombreuses
reprises de lobbying en 2019 par exemple
le journal Le Monde affirme après avoir
enquêté que Coca-Cola aurait dépensé 8
millions d'euros en France pour
influencer des professionnels de santé
et des chercheurs notamment pour
empêcher des publications négatives pour
pour la marque je vais pas m'étendre
plus longtemps sur ce sujet ici parce
que c'est pas le coeur de la vidéo
aujourd'hui mais il faut garder ça à
l'esprit et ça me semblait quand même
important de vous en parler aujourd'hui
revenons donc dans les années 90 il y a
cette polémique grandissante sur la
question des produits transformés sur la
question des sodas sur la question de
l'impact notamment en matière d'obésité
et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle notamment
pour Pepsi en effet je vous l'avais dit
un Pepsi avait fusionné avec Free
Twilight ce qui fait du coup qu'ils
étaient attaqué certes sur leur boisson
Pepsi mais aussi sur tous leurs autres
aliments qu'ils vendaient au quotidien à
ce moment là Pepsi a donc l'idée pour se
refaire en quelque sorte une image de
racheter quaker out alors quaker hots
vous connaissez peut-être cette
entreprise grâce au flocons d'avoine
qu'elle vend par exemple une marque qui
permet notamment de faire du porridge
et oui je prenais effectivement à titre
personnel du porridge au petit déjeuner
et ce que j'étais bizarre peut-être mais
bon vous allez pas me juger bref en
mettant la main sur des produits comme
ça PepsiCo se dit qu'il va pouvoir
redorer son image et donc augmenter à
nouveau ses ventes marques va alors
proposer un rachat pour 14,8 milliards
de dollars problème quicker roots refuse
de l'offre de Pepsi du coup je vous
laisse deviner qui entre dans cette
bataille pour obtenir la marque c'est
évidemment le patron de coca coca qui
fait une proposition à 16 milliards de
dollars précisément sauf qu'en fait le
patron de coca c'est un petit peu avancé
avec cette offre puisque globalement ça
ne plaît pas du tout au conseil
d'administration de coca coca qui n'a
pas envie de se retrouver en fait avec
des paquets de flocons d'avoine à devoir
vendre Pepsi va donc apprendre ça va
donc faire une nouvelle offre à 13,4
milliards de dollars moins d’ailleurs du
coup que la première offre pourtant
cette fois c'est gagné Pepsi achète
quickerhots y compris donc les flocons
d'avoine et Pepsi va donc commencer à
vendre aussi des produits plus sain
au-delà donc des sodas ou alors des
chips bon on approche de la fin la
guerre se poursuit nous sommes en 2001 à
ce moment-là la marque décide une
nouvelle fois de sortir un très gros
chèque clepsie nous à ce moment-là un
partenariat avec
Britney Spears espère donc reproduire le
même schéma qu'avec Michael Jackson
quelques années plus tôt mais le
résultat n'est pas vraiment à la hauteur
des espérances de la marque les ventes
continuent de baisser face à Coca-Cola
alors la marque tente une nouvelle
opération cette fois-ci en faisant appel
non pas une célébrité mais bien trois
célébrités avec en plus de ça donc
Beyoncé et pink qui s'ajoutent à Britney
Spears et bien les ventes de Pepsi
continuent de dégringoler
le seul petit réconfort que peut avoir
Pepsi c'est que les ventes de coca elles
aussi sont en baisse
et la raison de cette baisse c'est
notamment donc cette forme de
sensibilisation qui arrive au fil des
années concernant l'impact des boissons
sucrées sur notre santé bref à ce moment
là rien ne va plus pour les sodas et
maintenant c'est celui qui agira le plus
vite qui pourra s'en sortir alors Pepsi
au père de grands changements nouveau
logo nouveau design avec ce symbole
inspiré des emojis on est alors en 2009
et puis s'il y a des sites de frapper un
grand coup pour montrer tous ces
changements quel est l'événement sportif
le plus suivi aux Etats-Unis depuis des
années
YouTube
et bien c'est le Super Bowl avec ces
fameuses publicités à la mi-temps Pepsi
va même devenir le sponsor officiel du
concert de la mi-temps de Superbowl de
2013 à 2022 alors là vous attendez
peut-être à ce que je vous dise qu'un
tel événement a permis à Pepsi de
revenir dans ce marché mais en fait pas
tant que ça puis même quasiment au même
moment le Coca-Cola Light devient le
deuxième soda le plus vendeuse derrière
le coca classique
ça fait donc descendre Pepsi à la
troisième place chez Pepsi on est
furieux
les salariés accusent la direction de
cette éloigné de la véritable
identité du soda notamment en voulant
lancer des produits plus sains au moment
du rachat de Quick Heroes du côté de
Coca-Cola je l'ai dit un pas de
diversification certes il y a eu un
partenariat avec McDonald's ce qui a eu
pour impact de faire connaître le
Coca-Cola au grand public au fur et à
mesure de l'expansion de McDo mais
autrement pas de diversification pas de
flocons d'avoine de porridge de je ne
sais quoi et d'ailleurs pour elle ça
marche finalement plutôt bien Coca-Cola
décide même de lancer un nouveau produit
alors je rentre pas dans les détails
aujourd'hui des nouvelles saveurs ou
autre là en l'occurrence le nouveau
produit intéressant à observer c'est la
question des mini canettes c'est mini
canette qui contiennent deux fois moins
de boissons que les canettes classiques
à 15 cl donc mets des canettes qui
pourtant au litre au départ sont deux
fois plus cher et visiblement personne
ne voit le problème puisque ça marche
très très bien
viens en parallèle la branche
australienne de Coca-Cola a une idée de
génie personnaliser les bouteilles en
remplaçant le nom de la marque par les
150 prénoms les plus populaires dans le
pays la campagne est un tel succès
qu'elle les a ensuite développées dans
le monde entier les employés chez coca
débarque même dans les supermarchés ont
proposant de personnaliser les canettes
directement sur place pour la première
fois et bien les ventes de coca
remontent du coup Pepsi se dit qu'il
faut réagir encore une fois la marque
mise sur sa recette gagnante recouvrir à
des célébrités fait appel cette fois-ci
à Kendall Jenner mais attention vous
l'attendiez peut-être vous voulez
peut-être déjà vu tout ne se passe pas
véritablement comme prévu
[Musique]
vous l'imaginez gros bad buzz pour cette
publicité entre Kendall Jenner et Pepsi
on les accuse d'utiliser les mouvements
contestataires de citoyens pour faire
des profits pour une multinationale et
en fait pour comprendre les critiques il
faut avoir aussi en tête que on est dans
un contexte en 2017 ou les États-Unis
sont traversés par le mouvement Black
lives matter qui milite contre le
racisme envers les Noirs contre les
violences policières alors quand dans
les dernières secondes de la vidéo on
voit un policier sourire juste parce que
Kendall Jenner lui donne une canette de
Pepsi forcément ça fait beaucoup réagir
résultat en moins de 24 heures la
publicité est retirée
vous allez pas retirer en l'occurrence
d'Internet où elle reste encore présente
aujourd'hui je l'ai vu repasser sur
Twitter il y a encore quelques jours
mais franchement là dessus Pepsi a eu
pas mal de chance puisque finalement il
y a eu aucun véritable impact ni sur ses
ventes ni sur sa valeur en bourse
alors que s'est-il passé aujourd'hui qui
a gagné la bataille des sodas et bien
aujourd'hui les deux géants du soda ne
s'affrontent plus seulement donc sur le
soda mais sur toutes les boissons
gazeuses les eaux pétillants les jus de
fruits bref ils sont présents sur tous
les terrains c'est peut-être finalement
ce qu'il faut comprendre effectivement
il y a pas un seul gagnant aujourd'hui
mais il y a donc des entreprises qui au
fur et à mesure se diversifient à minima
sur la question des boissons en tout cas
les choses continuent à bouger puisque
il y a seulement quelques jours la
marque Pepsi a dévoilé un nouveau logo
clairement la marque veut mettre en
avant quelque chose de plus chic comme
pour montrer que c'est cool de boire un
Pepsi on verra donc si ça un impact en
tout cas vous l'aurez compris les deux
géants continuent à tenter de vendre le
plus possible le tout malgré des études
scientifiques qui ont prouvé à maintes
reprises que les soldats sont néfastes
pour notre santé ou encore les
accusations de surexploitation des
ressources naturelles dont certains pays
comme par exemple en Inde aujourd'hui
chaque seconde dans le monde c'est 17
360 bouteilles coca qui sont vendus
Coca-Cola domine Pepsi en termes de
boissons partout dans le monde sauf dans
quelques pays notamment l'un de l'Arabie
Saoudite ou encore le Guatemala et pour
info aujourd'hui c'est le Mexique qui
consomme le plus de Coca-Cola avec une
moyenne de 160 litres par personne et
par an en 2019 c'est lié notamment à du
coca parfois aussi cher que de l'eau sur
place en tout cas j'aime cette vidéo
vous a plu pensez à vous abonner je fais
pas encore le cas je rappelle que on a
deux chaînes YouTube là c'est notre
chaîne YouTube pas des actifs du jour
mais la chaîne dédiée à nos formats plus
longs vérifiez donc que vous êtes abonné
je mais c'est pas encore le cas
n'hésitez pas à le faire pour nous
soutenir j'espère en tout cas que cette
vidéo vous aura plu prenez soin de vous
et on se dit à très vite